Hi, I'm Erik Bosse
And with the vendors in-game behind us in looking ahead past spider-man far from home Marvel fans have now found ourselves in an unfamiliar sensation
uncertainty what comes next in the MCU is still very much a mystery and not a fun mystery like squirrel search or
Spidey duck hunt I just feel so helpless
Marvel Studios has announced it will be returning to Hall H at Comic Con this month during which
Kevin Feige will presumably make a little cameo to announce the Marvel phase 4 lineup in schedule just like you did in October 2014
Back when we all still believed Feige about that Inhumans movie that never happened. Oh, well oops there
I'm gonna break down what that lineup revealed at Comic Con might be and everything
We know at this point about the future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Ok, the most immediate release that we're waiting for information about is Disney's upcoming streaming service Disney Plus
Which will launch on November 12 2019 (Subtitle by *I am HeRe *in description at bottom)
There are currently 5 Marvel related series that will stream on Disney Plus (Subtitle by *I am HeRe *in description at bottom)
Falcon and Winter Soldier will begin production in October 2019 and is set to premiere on the service in August of 2020
It'll star Anthony Mackie and Sebastian Stan and could for all we know feature old man cap or younger alternate reality caps there will also
Be Marvel
What if an anthology series based on the hypothetical?
Premise spin-off comics that will also come out within the first year of the service with a pilot episode focusing on what if Peggy Carter
received the Super Soldier Serum
There's also one division a series with Scarlet Witch envision that will begin production in fall
2019 as well and the Loki series was announced with Rick and Morty writer Mike Waldron to produce with the premise being Loki affecting events
Throughout human history, and this will come out in the second year of the service probably sometime in 2021
Meanwhile, we are still waiting on details for an untitled Hawkeye series
That sounds like it'll feature Clint Barton mentoring Kate Bishop, but when it comes to major theatrical releases
The only movie Marvel has in production from what we know is Black Widow
Scarlett Johansson will star as Natasha Romanov and what will likely be a
2006 prequel in Budapest co-star in Florence pew probably as rival spy Elena Bulova as well as Rachel Weisz
David Harbor Oh teeth had been laying characters like Hawkeye and Nick Fury could also make cameos Kate
Shortland is directing and could be the movie that Marvel planned for its mystery May 20
2014 3 but the James Gunn drama delayed that release so a more likely release date for Black Widow would probably be November
2020 the next movie in the Marvel pipeline is the
Eternals in the Marvel Comics the Eternals were an offshoot of the process that created sentient life on earth
The Celestials created the Eternals initially to defend earth and it led to a war between the Eternals and the deviants
Angelina Jolie will star as
Cersei in a plot that has been described as a love story with the character Icarus who's gonna be played by Richard Madden aka Robb
Stark on Game of Thrones also joining the cast will be Kumail Nanjiani. Ma dongseok and Salma Hayek Khloe
Chou is directing and it's speculated that this could release sometime in summer
2021 moving on the next movie that we know about is the second Black Panther film director
Ryan Coogler is returning and the plan is to start production in late
2019 or early 2020 which could mean a February?
2021 release
remember in Avengers endgame the first characters to portal into that final battle or who to Tallis Shuri in Ocoee so that could be a
Sign for these characters be the priorities for Marvel's future next
We also know that a second Doctor Strange film is in the works
Scott derrickson will direct once again and see Robert Cargill is coming back to work on this script production is set to begin in
2020 and this could be another summer 2021 release or perhaps a November 2021 release after the first Doctor Strange came out in
2016 derrickson said that he was interested in Nightmare as a future villain and if he followed Erickson on Twitter
Which I highly suggested
He's a fascinating follow he tends to post some cryptic horror
Influences of his and images from the Doctor Strange comics that could indicate some kind of cosmic horror for the sorcerer supreme
Perhaps a journey into Hell itself
Another Marvel film in the pipeline is shang-chi
With destined Daniel cretton directing and David Callahan writing the script that the goal is to avoid
Asian stereotypes that a direct adaptation the comics might run into Ruby Lin and Ross Butler are
Speculated to be considered for the lead role and production will begin after production for the Eternals wraps
So we might be seeing a shang-chi movie dropping sometime early
2020 - and that brings us to guardians of the galaxy vol 3 now James Gunn has been
Rehired to direct but thanks to all that's due
But drama last summer
Production was delayed to give James gun time to direct Suicide Squad to for DC and time for the rest of the cast
Schedules to line up since this is very much an ensemble movie and everyone needs to have time to work together
I'm thinking we might be looking at a summer
2022 release for this one now coming out of endgame who suggested that it could be a possible as
Guardians of the galaxy team up with the work but James Gunn tweeted to stop calling it as guardians of the galaxy
Which might mean Thor won't be in this movie or gun just doesn't like puns in the title
Gunn has said that he wants the third movie to focus on the mystery of Rockets origin
perhaps related to the character the High Evolutionary
and of course after that
Post-credits scene from volume 2 Adam warlock will almost certainly factor into the story
and of course, we know at some point there will be a third Tom Hollands spider-man film probably with some home-related title like
You know can't go home again
Who knows we could see that as early as summer?
2021 with another two year gap considering far from home came out two years after homecoming now the post-credits scene for far from home
Indicates a possible direction the third movie could go go check out my breakdown of the post-credits scenes for details on that and similarly
We'll probably get a second Captain Marvel film which the far from home post credits scenes also might have shed some light on again check
out that breakdown
But I'm guessing the second film will introduce the adult Monica Rambeau
Aka spectrum who is established as a child in the first one
All of this said Kevin Feige would be nuts
If you didn't plan on some major tentpole crossover film
Considering phase 3 included Civil War infinity war and endgame my bet is that we will be seen an Avengers secret invasion
Announcement maybe Secret Wars and/or an introduction of the Fantastic Four and along with these other titles
I've mentioned there are several Marvel characters that Kevin Feige has brought up as possible
Future films this includes Nova whom Feige has named and director Adam McKay mentioned as they film being developed by Kia is also mentioned
kana Lacan who be the future first Muslim American superhero in the MCU Legion showrunner
Noah Hawley has said that he's written a Doctor Doom script that Marvel Studios is still in discussions with him about and according to reports
Some character in this new Marvel phase 4 will probably be played by Keanu Reeves
But who think we should launch a new investigation series kion who you don't love the title
Don't bother saying so in the comments because this is already a thing folks. So what do you think the mystery May 20?
21 major Avengers tentpole event
Do you want to happen in phase 4 comment down below with your thoughts?
Follow me on Instagram and Twitter at EA boss and subscribe to the rock stars for breakdowns and theories about everything Marvel related
thank you for joining me and I
Say about making fun of me, maybe not again